Let's see who else I can pick up on here.
How about let's go to the nine one seven area
code, if indeed that is someone in New York
City would love to hear what is going on there.
It is me.
Yes, it is.
Hi, how are you?
Good.
How are you?
Who's this?
This is Avery.
Great.
What's going on?
Oh, good.
I have a couple of questions.
OK?
I'm a software engineer and.
I'm very unsure how this entire election will
proceed.
It seems.
It seems like the American people aren't very
trustworthy when it comes to.
Elect, you know, online elections.
And I'm unsure how voting turnouts will be
pulled on who's regularly who's voting online.
I mean, online voting.
Yeah.
What states are doing online voting?
I don't know.
I don't know which states are going to be
doing online voting, but this is my worry.
But I don't think any a limited amount.
The question is in-person versus vote by mail.
Mm hmm.
Yeah.
Oh, OK, I see.
OK.
So it's going to be voting by mail.
Well, hopefully.
Yeah, I mean, that's the idea.
All right.
The states will transfer to voting by mail.
OK.
All right.
And it's not even really a transfer.
I mean, in reality.
So this is an important distinction.
What we're really talking about is just expanding
the absentee ballot systems that are already
there, like every state already has an absentee
ballot system.
Some states like Oregon have been exclusively
vote by mail since the 90s.
So we're not really talking about creating
any new systems.
We're just scaling up the existing vote by
mail systems that are there.
All right.
OK.
With just something that I've been that I've
been quite worried about.
Yeah.
But I haven't quite done enough research in,
so.
Thanks.
Thanks for that clarification.
But I also have another another question that
has been quite bothering me of late.
I'm not particularly Left-Wing or Right-Wing,
for that matter.
I'm more a more centrist.
And I don't see and I don't understand why
people are so anti Trump.
I've you know, I sat here on the on the phone
for 20 minutes listening to whatever his name
was because names being written.
And he was calling Trump perceive and a criminal
evil.
I see people in your comments.
You know, I, I just read one I think was an
hour ago.
Said Trump raped a 13 year old girl.
These these are a outrageous claims.
Well, hold on.
Let's let's take a step back.
Let's address a couple different things.
So, first of all, Trump was accused of raping
a 13 year old girl.
She ultimately, you know, dropped the suit
because it appears that there was huge, huge
pressure.
But that that's that that is the allegation
to say that it's true.
You know, we don't have proof of that.
I wouldn't look at YouTube comments necessarily.
But listen, the reason Trump is so bad is
he is incompetent in a way that is lethal.
It is lethal evidence.
100, 100 percent now.
That's roughly pedophilic spending increase
the deficit spending without cutting, without
cutting the budget.
Yeah, but that doesn't make them.
That doesn't make him evil or.
That's that's not that.
Debt is no political football.
They all do that.
But the lethal incompetence, the corruption,
the doing the opposite of everything he promised.
The hypocrisy and double standards you see
with this is where I'm not I'm not quite following
a guy.
I understand.
I understand all from an economics perspective.
I see.
And I understand what he's doing wrong.
OK, from a leadership point of view, I see
how he's incompetent.
Look how it runs his mouth and how it could
be dangerous, especially when handling people
like the president of China and the president
of North Korea.
Yeah, I see all of this.
OK.
And I'm I'm particularly not.
So I'm not a big fan of Trump for that reason.
But from the left, I see a big, you know,
a big character attack against Trump.
Sure.
He's a he has a big mouth and not but.
Okay.
But hold on all hold on every level.
Let me see if I understand.
So you're saying that Trump is terrible on
economics and his leadership has been a failure.
But you're not sure why the left dislikes
him so much?
I mean, that's why you know, and not to the
extent you don't like the tone of the left.
It's you know, if that's really what we're
set.
You don't like the way that some of the left
criticizes him.
OK.
I mean, I don't know.
It doesn't seem like a huge deal.
It's you know, if we're gonna talk about tone,
we've got to look at Trump.
But you said it yourself.
He's bad on economics and he's a failed leader.
I wouldn't say he's a failed leader, Persay.
He decided to do things that for my for my
his foreign policy is OK from my perspective.
He's not is most certainly not the most competent
man I would vote for.
But I don't I don't quite I don't quite understand
why there's such a harsh reaction from the
left.
So it sounds like every like you I see all
sorts of you don't.
I like Trump, but you don't like Trump and
you you're not exactly on the same page with
the left as to the degree to which you don't
like him.
Is that sort of what you're saying?
Well, yes, that that's one thing.
But I mean, I don't quite understand why it's
so harsh.
I see the left always looking for angles to
attack Trump on on, you know, with all with
the whole Russia conspiracy theory that lasted
for years, years.
Well, the coalition won four years.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
But this this whole scandal, this went four
years and then it plopped on its head and
I kept hearing on the news.
Russia.
Russian.
Well, now it sounds like it's just about the
news.
Not so much about the left.
Right.
I mean, I'm having trouble.
It's weird.
I'm having trouble following what your argument
is.
I guess you just don't think they'll know.
I said I don't know.
Certainly have an argument.
I'm trying to.
I'm trying to ask you why.
Why is there this.
Why is this particular harsh view of Trump
and his constant attacking, trying to find
the angles on him?
You know, find, you know, angles.
It's the you don't really need to go.
Finding angles.
You're talking about a guy who is in completely
over his head, doesn't listen to experts,
thinks he knows more than everybody, seems
emotionally unstable, doesn't understand economics,
doesn't understand public policy, doesn't
understand foreign policy, doesn't understand
geopolitics, can't take responsibility for
a single a single mistake, and is regularly
making errors that lead to people dying, as
we are seeing with coronavirus.
I don't know what you know, if you just don't
see that as warranting people on the left
being upset, then we probably just have different
values in the end.
Well, I don't know.
I don't see.
I hear would tell you the latest video where
Trump accused the city of yours and your channel
where Trump accused, I think it was a reporter,
wasn't a reporter at TV show host of accuse
him of murder.
Yes.
And then.
You didn't say anything.
Anything particular you didn't lay.
You know, the Corona virus deaths on his feet.
But I saw many you know, I saw many people
who did.
Yet Lisa Trump is not responsible.
He is not responsible for one hundred thousand
deaths.
But just one week earlier of saying we've
got to shut things down.
Could have saved 30000 people two weeks earlier.
Could have saved 50.
So certainly Trump is not responsible for
corona virus.
But his inaction is certainly tied to some
of the deaths.
Listen, my friend, I got to run, but I guess
I understand you just you're not you don't
see why the left dislikes Trump so much.
And and that's fine.
It sounds like we have we have sort of different
ways of evaluating, and that's that's OK.
But I'm just trying to tell you why many on
the left do see this as as a lethal the incompetent
man.
That's all the time I have recalls today.
Sorry I wasn't able to get to everybody.
But we will take calls again.